html is my favorite language for  programming website documents but  writing it by hand is no fun if you want  to go fast there's a tool called  emmett that's built into vs code and is  like snippets on steroids bang  tab and we've got a basic html page ctrl  g  go to line 10. type the name of any  element followed by a period add a class  or a hash to add an id hit tab to expand  don't touch the mouse yet hit ctrl enter  for a new line  this time i want a header plus a sibling  article element  in that article i want an unordered list  that contains a list  item no 5 list items and i want to put  some dummy text in each one  amazing but oh no i forgot something  i'll just use the balance outward  command to select the next parent  element then use wrap with abbreviation  to include the element that i forgot  [Applause]